foreign
comes from JC in Utah my wife and I are
on baby step two with 148 thousand
dollars in debt my wife who uses a
wheelchair works from home and we have a
nanny that takes care of our children
while she's working after reading Total
Money Makeover and listening to the
podcast I'm fired up and ready to knock
this debt out my wife is not a hundred
percent on board and would like me to be
less intense with a little time for
herself she enjoys splurging on takeout
and designer coffee and she thinks
ordering take out one to two times a
week is okay we use every dollar and can
budget for these expenses but I keep
hearing you in my head saying sacrifice
part of the challenge is I've done FPU
and she hasn't should I slow down and
wait until we are on the same page or
keep pushing on my own
oh that's tricky yeah this is a lot more
relational than it is financial we don't
have a lot of numbers here other than
they have a giant pile of debt at 148
000 no clue how much they make it could
be 60 it could be 300. but it doesn't
matter because the point of this is that
his wife is not on board she hasn't on
fbu she doesn't get it right and we
don't know how these conversations have
gone so far so has you know has JC come
in with a really honest and upfront
conversation that was calm and rational
or has it been kind of whiny and Naggy
that's kind of hard because Dave said
you can't eat and now his wife sees
Dave's name as a cuss word
yeah we often recommend you know you
want this to be an adventure and an
exciting thing and you know a lot of
times somebody one spouse gets so on
board and they're just like yes and they
go so hard that they kind of scare off
the other spouse oh yeah don't do that
Pro tip guys never never use that
approach of going through a few by
yourself first of all because then they
have no idea what you're talking about
and you're just coming in yelling gotta
be Excel intense Dave said we can't eat
out that's not gonna work and so JC
number one get her to go through FPU
with you if she's unwilling to do that
it tells me there's probably some deeper
marital problems here that may require
some counseling to go hey we can't even
talk about money without it being a blow
up fight and this is a deeper issue yeah
and I mean women tend to be wired for
relationships and security so you know
come at that conversation with you know
your heart for helping secure the family
finances for the future I mean a hundred
and forty eight thousand dollars in debt
that's a lot of debt that really puts
you guys in a vulnerable position so I
just think you could frame that
conversation in a way that really speaks
to her heart but lets her know hey I'm
not just trying to do this to make you
give up your coffees and take out I'm
not just trying to make your life
inconvenient I'm trying to do this
because I see a vision for our future
where we're not carrying around this
massive debt and we're not stressed out
and our children can have that security
and we can leave them a legacy like try
try to kind of reframing the
conversation in a way that really speaks
to her heart and just encourages her
yeah and what I'm seeing here is she
would like me to be less intense well
the other side of intensity is
complacency
and that's not somewhere we need to hang
out very long because that is how we got
into 148k in debt in the first place is
just kind of wandering through our
financial life and just we'll worry
about hey that's a that's a future
George problem they don't need to worry
about that right now and so my guess is
she's not very involved in finances at
all because someone here is stressed and
it sounds like it's JC because he's been
crunching the numbers going 148
000 in payments adds up to thousands of
dollars a month and we can scrape by
right now probably because they have a
great income if they can afford a nanny
and take out and coffee I mean that's
the American dream right there but the
problem is this is designed to a
nightmare designer coffee I've never
heard of that term
so the question he asked was should I
slow down and wait until we're on the
same page or keep pushing on my own I
don't think you should slow down I do
think you need to be on the same page
because pushing on your own is just
going to push you guys further apart and
you're gonna have so much resentment
towards her because you're over here
busting your butt and she's just
drinking her designer coffees and
getting takeout
well and she's probably getting yelled
at and getting you know kind of the
brunt of the you know you're holding us
back and this is not moving forward
because because
um and so yeah really taking that time
to get on the same page yes
so so important I think you you know
what to do it's just not going to be
easy to have these conversations and get
somewhere and part of that is she's got
to understand the shared common language
that you learned in Financial Peace
University that gave you this Vision
that you now have to get out of debt
with what we call Gazelle intensity so
she's got to do that as the foundation
here if we're going to get anywhere good
luck my man that's not an easy situation